kamilla Kibeho is assuring fans the
shambhala love is still alive thank you
very much
the Havana singer took to social media
today to respond to rumors her and Shawn
Mendes have split she wrote in her
Instagram story
well when the were you gonna tell me and
tagged her beau Kibeho posted the
comment over a headline claiming to have
proof of their breakup this is my best
self within hours of chaos post the
stiches singer shared this sweet snap of
him and his lady in love I can never
find myself answering questions simply
caballos post comes weeks after she
dropped the l-word in regards to mendez
you guys just looks unhappy at a moment
is that is that the case yeah we're
pretty happy i really any love him a lot
well I think that I've been just I feel
like I've just gotten to know myself
really well this year and besides like
everything that I've you know the
amazing things that have happened in my
career I feel like I just feel really I
just feel really like appreciative of
being able to like live and I feel like
I just know what's important in in life
right now so I'm just I'm really happy
and I feel very I don't I feel like
really in touch with my emotions
[Music]